I actually oddly enough have a small
nitpick for this particular video
because when they're talking about how
Halloween kicked off all these different
trends and stuff in slasher movies they
pulled images from the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre which came before like five
years or so before Halloween no there's
no way that Halloween could have
inspired those those things screen
junkies they're good good examples of
those things but you know yeah right
October 1st 1974 do your homework what
gives you anything about me you know
anything's you got one thing wrong with
this whole videos de bum also you never
did an honest trailer for my favorite
movie so you suck and you didn't talk
about the Rob Zombie ones in your cram
it video for all the Halloween movies
lazy
you call this complete G screen junkies
[Laughter]
we mean all of them were never sarcastic
happy to say reject nation of Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey if you guys have not
seen our Halloween 2018 spoiler review I
hope you go check that out put a lot of
thought into it it's kind of long but
whose isn't
anyway we're gonna watch today screen
jug is honest trailers for Halloween the
1978 edition a movie that a lot of
people love some people hail is the
greatest horror movie of all time that I
personally think is just okay before we
go into this I wanted to say thank you
to everyone who's been following us on
our patron page over there we do TV show
reactions and weekly Q&A s the TV show
reactions include shows such as attack
on Titan my hero academia and Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood as well as
Riverdale Gotham and supernatural so go
check out our patreon and see if you
want to become a patron oject today
let's film I know Dan Murrow loves this
movie so let's see how much the love is
infused
Wow there was before you see Halloween
Oh the sequel to the original Halloween
but not having and definitely not this
father movie called Halloween - you okay
wait let me start over before you see
the third Halloween to visit Halloween
the first one I know you're joking but
Lindsay's a child creep but this year a
killer is on the loose and he's
inventing or cementing every slasher
cliche will get for the next 40 years
that way by wearing a poopy bad poopy
phone call was only targeting suburban
teenagers I'm loving the final virgin
girl survived and eating dogs sir was
that Mars the only one who actually eats
a dog's probably for the best
before Jamie Lee Curtis was a scream
queen her mom was in psycho that's right
making her a beer screen princess watch
your intentions Laurie I survived the
night with her friend Annie and a hole
and would starve the drinking game take
a shot every time Linda says totally
[Music]
soli the best Halloween ever you guys
totally happy together as a babysitter's
cross I want to see wires one of silver
that's iconic mouth-breathers forget
Instagram because he's stalking girls
the old-fashioned way landing in clear
view of um then somehow bad Manning into
thin air when their breath but Michael
is just a monster made by the film's
real Frankenstein Loomis a psychiatrist
with a very loose grasp of psychiatry I
spent ages trying to reach him and then
another seven trying to keep him locked
up
who doesn't exactly go really messed up
this kid's face at some point and
doesn't even obey handicapped parking
sighs I need an unstoppable killing
machine okay fine but you were parked
outside a medical facility sir where is
your placard did so strap in over at the
greatest horror films of all time from
carpenters Natalie test directing and
original score
- Debra Hills racer focused riding in
production - Jamie Lee Curtis his star
turn against a brand-new horror icon
just be sure to follow the upcoming
sequels lead and pretend none of the
other movies ever happen as Russ does
[Music]
bus survives the best half tempest house
Dory the shape of slaughter and glory
strode up to the wrong house that's for
sure Casey Affleck Oh our secret chai
bone and got yourself a hacksaw and he
kissed his wife and his two children
goodbye and then he proceeded the horny
brand the somewhat less horny but still
kind of with the mystery creeper in the
backseat of this car
while Michael drives yeah there's
someone else in the back of the car it's
probably Loomis you know the real horror
is living in a home or your parents only
buy you the Kirkland select knockoff
comic books laser man Neutron man worst
Wow universe ever ever person's apple
fritter
riboflavin Oh Josh
I thank my god
and Lansbury would wit you know what
that's big that's bait yeah Halloween is
a film that I really appreciate because
well like they point out here it
invented a lot of tropes that were to be
repeated to be followed it birthed a
bunch of other French guys that wanted
to be essentially what it is birth the
slasher franchise a lot of people kind
of forget that it is the birth of so
many of those things it is the one that
really kicked off the trend I mean their
movies like dark Christmas or the
original Texas Chainsaw that came
slightly before but didn't really like
spark the crazy Halloween pushed it over
the hump you know I know there are
people who think this movie is
near-perfect
I know there are people who love it
sometimes though the argument made for
that sounds like that just because it
came first it means it's the best yeah I
don't necessarily appreciate this film
but you know honestly if I were to be
involved in this honest trailer it's
kind of boring I think it's a little
boring I don't need a lot of crap for
that I personally think yeah yeah it's
gonna kind of tedious at times for me to
watch it does have kind of a patience
talking quality which I can see kind of
why you wouldn't be as thrilled by that
and it does have that sort of Snuffy
like you're just kind of watching as
Michael kind of stuck like literally
stalks for a while before he actually
gets back to any actual killing or
anything like that certain times where
that's cool element that's that's what
makes the movie where you put it out is
what makes the movie work no yeah I just
think that there are times this is not
that engaging people fell in love with
Laurie Strode I never loved Laurie
Strode
until this David Corcoran was the first
I'm like I love Laurie
for me at least it's like I saw a whole
bunch of other slasher movies before I
saw the original Halloween that might
have done something to my experience
yeah so it's like you start out with
stuff that's like a lot different in the
pacing and a lot different than the
kinds of kills and stuff like that and
it's weird to go back to the simplicity
there's Halloween there's tons to
appreciate and some of I'm kind of with
you on it's like I think I like it more
than you but I'm not like oh it's one of
my favorite feelings I think it's funny
how they were talking about how this
like franchise is all over the place and
everything and you know not to get
things confused but then recent
Halloween movie is I think the
highest-grossing like opening for any
slasher movie like a slasher movie for a
movie with a lead over hi email
second-highest October October you don't
smash it in its first weekend outperform
Rob Zombie's first Halloween and that
had that even held a record that's
something like Labor Day or whatever Day
weekend yeah which is I think like a
thirty million yeah so even though this
franchise is all over the place it's
still one hell of a moneymaker
yeah yeah I mean it's definitely earned
its legacy I really like how they
pointed out his messed-up face there's
no explanation to how that happened in
the movie maybe
Debra hill and John Carpenter did have
some reasoning because I don't think
everything needs to be explained as long
as the writer and director know
something so maybe the same time I have
the impression that they probably did
that so you can kind of hide his face
for when the mask comes off yeah because
sure the first time you see Michael
without a mask on before he's obviously
put away in the psychiatric unit or in
prison whatever he's a kid and he has a
perfectly fine face and then when he cut
to him later on when he you see his mask
off her split second heat because it's
like scar yeah yeah yeah and like the
hospital or did you have some kind of
bad experience with electroshock therapy
yeah I'm eating dogs I wish I kind of
wish they did it cuz I mean I would have
hated it because in Halloween he kind of
kills a lot of dogs in the franchise and
Halloween to of Rob Zombie's that's a
yeah usually the hours of pieces on that
yeah you'd like to stab that dog to
death like freaking really eats it it's
disturbing as hell yeah everything in
Halloween to Rob's out
Bob's obvious hello heat it was pretty
brutal and disgusting and scuzzy and
Nancy yeah you know the one thing I wish
they commented on his station wagon
steal that I mean yeah like where do you
learn to drive well yeah like I think it
does add kind of a silly layer to that
movie to think that Michael just
cruising around town half the time
station wagon wagon and it's like where
did he learn to drive in also some ways
of how he got body like the body that's
hanging yeah you can show it here
because she sees the body attain or sees
her friend and then it covered you know
which one comes first within that same
sequence yeah what is this hang it's
like what I want to see the Michael
Myers movie where they leave in all the
extra parts just like hoisting up a body
like tying it to something and testing
out like is it gonna swing right time
because like it's implies that Michael
is actually like a really smart like
engineer of some kind or yeah good at
thinking on his feet to freak people out
which is kind of weird when you think of
Michael as you know the emotionless
killing machine you know because it
seems like he wants to toy with his
victim I think it's kind of silly how
some people harp on the silliness of the
new one this on his trailer even they're
not making stuff up or just nitpicking
these issues it the movie how does he
disappear exactly it's like the one time
it's only gotten on my nerves in in
terms of why because all the other times
anyone is like in the bushes when
they're walking down he disappears oh my
god maybe he like just [ __ ] sprinted
when she's looking at Michael and and
and the laundry clothes in the
clothesline yeah and then he just
disappears while she's looking silly
things in this movies so I don't know
I'm not bothered by anything silly and
the new one that some people are getting
upset about I mean there are ways in
which it's dated and there are things I
don't know when it's anything that's
silly in a franchise installment of a
franchise that's already had silly
elements I tend to forgive that because
I'm just used to that aesthetic from
this yeah we're out of this video I want
to give a patient the day shout out to a
man named John Minnie now look guys I
sometimes make a joke about how some
our patrons look like serial killers I
saw the new Halloween the images you get
of Michael before he actually has the
mask on looks exactly like an older
version of John me yeah John many on
Google Hangouts John I know you got a
hot-ass wife she's a cook I'm starting
to get into the impression that maybe
you kill people and she cooks them have
her cook you a dog Trump supporter put
him away oh just for that yeah just give
Michael Myers with the maggot hat yeah
yeah same guy in a red jumpsuit that
could be John and then you know it'll be
and you have a nice little bridge with
the Rob Zombie ones cuz you got that big
old beard you know John I'm just messing
with you buddy miss you man haven't
talked to you in a while hope you're
watching this video my good luck to you
and your hot ass wife but a baby in the
oven soon and then eat it alright guys
well thanks for tuning in you can
subscribe to the reject nation and hey
why don't you click that notification
about this blue YouTube people check us
on patreon because I've talked about it
three times now alright bye